not all loves are created equal as far
as the brain is concerned studies have
looked at activity in the brain when
recalling passionate or romantic love
versus say maternal love and finds that
different centers definitely are more
active than the words they put people
into the functional MRI and they said
think about your partner or think about
your lover and certain areas lit up or
they said think about your mom and
different areas lit up which is
important because different areas are
responsible for the release of different
neurotransmitters which then come to
affect your future feeling states and
future behaviors so during romantic or
passionate love what happens from a
neurotransmitter standpoint those
chemicals that are released when you
have that particular experience dopamine
goes up dopamine is essentially the
neurotransmitter of reward so it is a
neurotransmitter that's released when
you have new or novel experience but
particularly experiences that are
reinforcing like gambling or something
that is really addictive in fact
literally addictive it's the
neurotransmitter if you snorted cocaine
that is most responsible for Wow
that was great and I totally want to do
it again so that is a neurotransmitter
that definitely goes up when you are in
the throes of romantic or passionate
love and what does that mean for you it
means that you're going to feel the
sense of being addicted to your partner
and in fact it's also the
neurotransmitter that goes up for people
who have obsessive compulsive disorder
does that mean you're going to develop
OCD no but what it does mean is you're
probably going to obsess over your
partner in comes another
neurotransmitter that's called serotonin
it is definitely a neurotransmitter that
is active for obsessive compulsive
disorder and it means that your problem
and for the
crushin do you become depressed no you
really don't but what you do do is a
feature of depression called rumination
so you think about your partner over and
over and over again in this really
obsessive manner and if your partner is
separated from you you're going to have
this longing where you're you know
wanting to be with them kind of like
you'd want to be with a drug if it was
taken away from you and you were already
addicted to it there are changes in
other neurotransmitters as well so if
you're physically with your partner the
neurotransmitter oxytocin which is kind
of known as the cuddle transmitter
neurotransmitter and that makes you feel
like warm and snuggly and intensely
bonded to this person it is particularly
released following orgasm so you know if
you're having sex with your partner and
things go well you're gonna feel very
attached to them exceedingly intimate
with them partially because of that
neurotransmitter there are other
neurotransmitters that actually also
change vasopressin which has to do with
stress level and so there's this whole
pan of plateau flicker of a release of
neurotransmitters that make you feel you
know very obsessed very addicted
thinking constantly about them very
intimately cuddly attached and and
stressed actually it is a stressful
condition to some degree to be really
into your partner so all of these
neurotransmitters can definitely be
released in lust okay which I'm going to
say is like the earliest stage perhaps
and so that's why to some degree it can
be good to give it a little bit of time
before you invest too much in this
person cuz you can go right up into sort
of a wonderful addictive
neurotransmitter state and not have this
be the greatest partner for you and
before you as it were invest your
resources you know whether we're talking
about you know emotional resources
financial resources and genetic
resources in terms of for example having
children you do want to give that
initial blip some time to come down so
that you can have some reason over
whether this is a good partner choice in
terms of the science to support what is
a good partner choice for the long haul
it does seem that having very similar
values and to some degree having a lot
of similarities in general often leads
to a longer term ability to maintain the
relationship and why is that and and I'm
not talking now about sexual
compatibility I'm not talking about that
you know wonderful passionate feeling
but I'm I'm really talking about just
maintaining any relationship it is
easier when you have fewer bridges to
cross so over time as this whole
neurotransmitter thing settles out
what's left to be able to maintain your
relationship going forward if you're
arguing over everything because
basically you fundamentally don't agree
on most things that is a challenge not
saying it's a challenge that can't be
managed and I certainly wouldn't say for
example that opposites can't attract
because they often do but the question
is what do you do with that down the
road if your different religion if you
believe differently and how money should
be managed if you have different goals
in terms of family rearing career
aspirations long-term how you want to
live your life these are bridges that
have to be crossed with a lot of
communication and a lot of compromise to
some degree studies support the less
compromise you have to make be easier
and you know that's very that's not
surprising right that's that's easy to
understand so so choosing someone with
some similarities will make for less
compromise down the road
and then the question becomes how good
are you and your partner individually at
communication at compromise at being
able to make choices that really aren't
your first choice for the service of
some greater good the thing about all
this neurotransmitter release is it's
it's very prevalent during new
passionate love but it's difficult to
maintain and that's why you know we're
talking all the time about people like
it was great at the beginning and then
like where did the fire go and that's
because the state doesn't tend to remain
over time it may remain for several
years actually but to keep the kind of
passionate love going that most people
do it particularly if they get married
want to for life you really have to work
at stoking some of these
neurotransmitters so for example I might
be telling someone who's come to me and
said you know we're just not you know we
love each other but we don't feel in
love anymore and how do we keep the
fires going I'm gonna tell you to do
things like new novel activity because
that is going to raise dopamine and that
is going to help keep that whole system
in place for you to some degree I'm
going to tell you to have sex more
frequently because and I'm going to tell
you how to have better sex so that you
can hopefully be having an orgasm with
your sex so that you could be releasing
some of that oxytocin and keeping that
really intimate cuddly bonding feeling
together so looking at these different
areas and trying to advise you to do
things that raise neurotransmitters in
the same way that your brain does
automatically when you are first in
passionate love